thank you
SEO is an important part of the
marketing strategy in case your website
doesn't show up on the first page of the
search engine then you need to work on
it to solve all your SEO related
problems we've come up with a solution
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and today we will be discussing the top
10 tips that every marketer needs to
know so let's get started and see the
first step
the first step is voice search now voice
search will impact search queries in
2021 according to dialogtech.com
in the United States of America 55
percent of the households will have
their own smart speaker by 2022.
well that's a lot so if you're planning
to optimize your voice search consider
choosing wise keywords
find out longer phrases that Searchers
use in daily life conversation
voice search is a more suitable way for
searching long and more natural sounding
phrases creating detailed and relevant
answers are essential when optimizing
for voice search so always remember to
create Persona based content
next create web pages that can answer
FAQ use
because when Searchers ask a question
they begin their question with words
like who when whom what however there
are many reasons for using voice search
such as dictating text messages looking
for a video on YouTube calling a person
from your contact list asking for
directions
Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is reduced
now the second step in the process is
the mobile optimization
now you must already know how important
it is to make your site mobile friendly
for a better user experience but did you
also know that having a mobile friendly
application impacts your search engine
optimization
sem Rush confirms that by the year 2025
approximately 70 percent of Internet
users will access the internet through
mobile devices
Google's mobile friendly update has
resulted in a big change in search
rankings with the help of Google's free
mobile friendly test have a look at how
effective your mobile website is also
take a peek at the mobile usability
report in Google's search console
now let's talk about tip number three
that is Google's eight principles Google
has confirmed that content quality is an
essential factor for ranking on search
engine result pages
but what does quality mean to Google
well content that fulfills the Google
eat principle will rank higher each
stands for expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness
these elements will determine if a web
page has a useful quality content
Google uses the combination of
algorithms to deliver the best results
for users Google Panda is one of the
famous algorithms of Google which
emphasizes delivering high quality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have low quality and
duplicate content not just that there is
one more algorithm called rank brain
ranked brain is a processing algorithm
that uses machine learning to interpret
search queries that users search on
Google whereas the searched query may
not have the right keywords that were
searched for
example
when you're searching for chocolate cake
recipes you will also get results for
chocolate truffle cake recipes on the
search engine results page Google Panda
and rankbrain send Bots to crawl each
and every website and as a result shows
high quality content on the top of the
search engine results page
next is our tip number four featured
snippet
these results are featured on the top
part of the page
Google programmatically chooses the best
answer from the third party website and
displays it on the featured snippet
here's what a featured snippet looks
like
according to ahrefs for a specific
search query almost 99 of web pages
shown in the featured snippet already
rank on serp's first page some of the
ways to optimize featured Snippets are
organize your content in a structured
way make sure one article answers many
similar questions use eye-catching
images and the last point is to create
answers with tables to drive clicks and
write dedicated headings to answer
featured Snippets like is red meat
healthy suppose you want to create
Snippets plan on creating question based
questions along with the relevant
keywords for ideas you can also look at
the Google search function that is
usually written in the blue color
and it reads out as people also ask so
now let's move to the fifth tip
image optimization according to sem Rush
image optimization will play a prominent
role in search in case the images on
your website aren't optimized make sure
to take care of them right now remember
to use high quality images relevant
images and use a suitable label for your
image file include images in your site
map as it becomes easier for the Bots to
crawl and finally use alt tags as
crawlers use it to classify the images
alt text is displayed on the web page
when an image fails to load on a user's
screen it is also utilized by Google to
drive meaning from images
a well optimized image can improve your
page ranking and increase the engagement
on it image optimization can help your
web page show up in the image carousels
on search engines
next we have semantically related
keywords
semantic search will have become an
important factor for ranking in the
future semantic keywords are linked to
the primary keywords
they drive relevant traffic on search
engine result pages
a simple way to look for LSI keywords is
on Google serp
semantic search can be performed wisely
by writing content that targets the
question that your target audience is
looking for
remember to optimize content for topic
clusters instead of focusing solely on
keywords and finally use structured data
and pick your semantic keywords this can
also be done with the help of a
comprehensive keyword tool it finds out
semantically related keywords
next comes tip number seven building
quality links
building quality links to your website
is important if you are aiming to manage
a successful and long-term SEO strategy
building quality links cannot be ignored
in 2016 Google declared that building
quality links are one of their top three
ranking signals always opt for quality
over quantity
as building quality links to your
content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in serps
let me share a few effective strategies
that will increase the number of links
pointing to your website dramatically
the first one
earn backlinks from relevant and
authoritative web pages next promote
your content regularly on social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram
and start your own page then participate
in forums to engage with your target
audience start your blog and attract
your target audience with your valuable
content
finally get listed in the high quality
link directories this will help you
build links from authoritative websites
next number eight is local search
listings
local SEO is the practice of optimizing
a website in order to obtain traffic
from location-based searching it is the
best way to Market your products and
services to local customers
according to Google local results are
based on relevance distance and
prominence these factors help Google to
find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the internet
sem Rush confirms that local search
listings will play a larger role in the
SEO strategies
suppose you want to know how to get your
business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own for this it is also important
to have a strong backlink profile
next we have number nine that is improve
the user experience
for the past few years ux has become an
important ranking factor for Google
however more and more SEO Specialists
have gained an interest in ux
ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor consider the
partnership of search engine
optimization and user experience
this way the search engine optimization
focuses on search engines and user
experience targets website visitors
so both share a common goal of giving
users the best result
this is what the content King app says
about the user experience
let me show you a few practices on how
to effectively leverage ux designs to
provide your site's SEO performance
simplify your site's navigation a good
site architecture helps to gain traffic
utilize ux design to SEO friendly
layouts which means make content easy to
digest infused images and videos
whenever possible use ctas very wisely
and finally optimize for site load speed
optimize for mobile responsive design as
more than 50 percent of all the traffic
is now driven by mobile search
in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement
and finally we come to our 10th and last
tip
that is using schema markup
according to search metrics 36 percent
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup
schema markup is microdata that every
individual can add to his website in
order to give an enhanced description to
users on a search engine results page
in simple words schema markup is used to
define website content
adding structured data will give your
website a significant SEO boost and
increase your rankings
some of the schema markup examples are
ratings and reviews image thumbnails
product availability and finally site
links
adding schema markup to your HTML is one
of the ranking factors
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on SEO tips I hope it was
informative and interesting if you have
any questions about the topics covered
in this video please ask in the comment
section below our team will help you
solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you feel this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here